breaks he's never really started from a  backward position  but okay we see now that he means  business he has  switched clothes the chat was unlucky so  uh  now he is ready for action i think he's  perhaps taking my advice  fresh class set of clothes fresh energy  i mean i really do believe in that  you've got to surround yourself with  something that makes you happy and i do  think  magnus means business but wesley seems  to have  frozen well but magnus is short didn't  it save clever  what what happened there lucky it was  the same color  and it said clever and then he left for  like five seconds coming back with  a different shirt magic magic  yeah i was about to make a pun on the  the clever t-shirt i know he's  keeping us guessing magnus and okay he  doesn't look super  confident right now but he's just got to  hope that this changed this kind of  fresh  fresh energy that ivanka mentioned that  that will give him a bit of luck